let's talk about the top diseases
that
are in reality
nutritional deficiencies
is it possible that certain diseases
could really be just nutritional
deficiencies well that's what we're
going to talk about you know when you go
to the doctor with your disease there's
not a lot of deep dive into vitamin or
mineral deficiencies at all
that's kind of off the radar maybe if
you have anemia they might look at iron
or even b12 but typically they're not
looking for nutrient deficiencies in
fact from my experience they don't
really look at the cause for any of
these conditions it's mainly
making sure that they correctly diagnose
you and then jump right into the
treatment but let's take a look at a
couple things
there's over 250 million preschool
children worldwide that have a severe
vitamin a deficiency which makes them
prone to blindness so without enough
vitamin a you can very easily develop
all sorts of diseases not just with your
eyes
but with your immune system with your
skin you can have acne dermatitis
all sorts of things now let's talk about
vitamin e if you don't have enough
vitamin e in your body
what suffers is the inside of the
arteries vitamin e is one of the main
antioxidants that helps prevent
lesions and
inflammation in the inside of the artery
and so a lack of e could set you up for
a whole cascade of issues we start
building up calcium deposits or
cholesterol deposits and the artery
becomes plug it all starts with the
lesion that can occur because you don't
have enough vitamin e to protect the
inside of the arteries
also without enough vitamin e
the heart muscle itself can lose oxygen
and you can be at risk for angina which
is chest pain this is why vitamin e is
good for anything muscular and they call
vitamin e the natural nitroglycerin
because nitroglycerin is what they use
to stop
heart attacks all right vitamin d
can a lack of vitamin d cause a disease
the answer is yes
osteoporosis or osteopenia which is a
pre-osteoporosis state you can even have
osteomalacia which is softening of the
bones a lack of vitamin d can set you up
for an infection if you're low in
vitamin d you'll tend to have high blood
pressure unfortunately when you go to
the doctor they're probably not going to
recommend vitamin d if you have high
blood pressure when it would be a good
idea if they did that
also in the past vitamin d was used for
tb tuberculosis because it's a great
remedy they have found that patients
with tb are nearly always deficient in
vitamin d which sets the person up or
makes them more susceptible or
vulnerable to getting tb so it's
intimately involved with the disease
process asthma is definitely associated
with a vitamin d deficiency
depression okay i've known many many
people who were depressed that then
increased their vitamin d that then
we're now no longer depressed all right
then we get to iron
if you don't have enough iron
your blood is not going to be able to
carry oxygen we need iron as the key
mineral to be able to
carry oxygen
in your hemoglobin and without it you're
going to get anemic so you can have a
loss of your air you're not going to be
able to breathe that well you're going
to be kind of pale
tired then we have b12 you can develop
another type of anemia from lacking b12
but there are a lot of other diseases
that a lack of b12 will also create okay
what about zinc if you don't have enough
zinc a lot of things will happen
you could develop dermatitis
inflammation of the skin you could
develop an infection because zinc is
intimately involved with the function of
your white blood cells and this is why
so many people are taking zinc and
vitamin d
when they get an infection or when
they're run down to try to speed up the
recovery and overcome that infection
also if you're zinc deficient you get a
condition called
hypogonadism
okay so in other words the testicle
shrinks and your testosterone goes down
also you'll develop a loss of taste and
smell and you can even develop diarrhea
i mean in certain countries there's a
lot of small children that die from
diarrhea because they're zinc deficient
now if you had high blood pressure
the two
really central key nutrients involved in
that would be a lack of vitamin d
and a lack of potassium the problem is
when you test potassium in the blood
you're not going to find a deficiency
because the majority of potassium is
inside the cell so you would have to
know that and also do an intracellular
potassium test and that would give you a
lot of good information to see if you
actually had a true potassium deficiency
but
so many people have high blood pressure
because they just don't have enough
potassium in the diet now the partner of
potassium is magnesium right another
mineral that is mostly located inside
the cell that's why you have to do an
intracellular
test
but if you're low in magnesium you could
develop atrial fibrillation or some
other type of arrhythmia now there are
classical nutritional deficiencies that
most people know about scurvy with
vitamin c rickets with vitamin d
pellegra which is a severe skin disorder
with b3 and beriberi which is a
neurological disorder now of course the
thought is that we don't have these
major problems anymore maybe in certain
countries that are very very poor but
what about
a sub clinical deficiency maybe the
person doesn't have a major deficiency
but let's say they have a subclinical
deficiency that they might not express
all of this characteristics of this but
just some can we actually create health
without nutrients is it possible and the
answer is
no well on the flip side if nutrients
are so involved in your health then a
lack of them are going to be involved in
the disease process this makes only
logical sense
let's take a look at
two things the foods that are
recommended for a healthy body
versus
the foods that you really need to eat
i'm talking about the eat lancet
commission if you haven't heard about
this group you'll hear more about it
i've done a video on it it's a group of
researchers that want to do radical
changes to your diet and it's not just
to one country it's to the whole planet
they want to have a planetary health
diet
by the year
2050 and they use all the buzzwords like
it's sustainable
it's healthy
well it's definitely not sustainable for
a healthy body and i'm going to explain
why they want to make your diet mostly
grains 232 grams of grains every single
day
like corn and wheat and all the other
grains potato cassava
50 grams okay
vegetables 300 grams
fruits 200 grams
milk 250 grams
and this right here meat 14 grams okay
that's what they want you to eat that
would basically be one mouthful of meat
okay talking about beef pork lamb things
like that
eggs
13 grams okay wow we're really rationing
the meat and eggs but you can have the
fake meat
and the soy burgers no problem
okay legumes 75 grams
nuts
50 grams and of course we can't have a
healthy diet without this right here
sugar 31 grams that's 7.5
teaspoons now what is sustainable or
healthy
about adding sugar that's what i have a
question about now on top of all this
what you need to know
is there's something called phytic acid
that's in the grains the nuts and the
legumes phytic acid is an acid in the
fiber of these foods that bind
certain minerals
especially zinc
iron
calcium magnesium potassium okay
and then we have oxalates okay oxalates
are in the beans they're in the
vegetables they're in the seeds and the
grains what do oxalis do they bind the
calcium
they make calcium unavailable we also
have tannins in these foods right here
also binding iron and other minerals as
well as depleting vitamin b1 and of
course the sugar you've seen this in my
other videos it's going to deplete you
of b1 zinc potassium magnesium
and calcium
so the foods that they want you to eat
just don't match what you really need to
be eating let's take a look at these key
nutrients that are involved in disease
processes okay all right let's start
with vitamin a where do you get vitamin
a well
you might say vegetables right there's
tons of vitamin a kale has vitamin a
spinach is vitamin a
well
it really doesn't have the active form
of vitamin a retinol it's the retinol
that prevents blindness unfortunately
they change the definition of vitamin a
to include
beta-carotene okay beta-carotene
so when you see that vegetables have
tons of vitamin a they're really talking
about beta-carotene beta-carotene has to
convert
to retinol retinol is the thing that
really is needed by the retina of your
eye
and so beta-carotene is good for other
things
but only three percent of it is
converted to retinol the active form of
vitamin a and take a while guess where
you might get retinol
from
animal products okay meats
egg yolk
things like butter spinach and carrots
might give you the precursor but it
doesn't give you the retinol very much
of it anyway let's take a look at what
it would take
to get 9 000
micrograms of vitamin a and i'm talking
about the retinol you can have three
ounces of liver beef liver or you can do
40 pounds of raw carrots
or 50 cups of cooked kale
or
454 cups of raw kale so you can go ahead
and pick which one you want to be able
to get your vitamin a at your next meal
all right let's talk about iron okay
you probably hear that oh iron it's in
spinach it's in vegetables well that's
the a different form that's the non-heme
form okay there's two different forms
one is more biologically available the
other one is not
so the one that is very biologically
available is the heme iron and that is
only in animal products as far as
non-heme iron as far as absorption you
get between one and fifteen percent okay
the heme iron you get 25 to 40 percent
and then if we look at trying to get our
iron
from this diet with all of these things
blocking iron
i'd be surprised if you had any iron in
your body at all what about b12
only in animal products okay
now what about zinc
do you get the same amount of zinc from
plant
versus animal and the answer is no
the best bio-available form of zinc is
in red meat it's in other animal
products it's also in seafood shellfish
and fish and remember we have the
anti-nutrients phytic acid that are
going to bind that zinc
with the whole grains
legumes and even nuts what about this
dha that's a really important omega-3
fatty acid right well where do you get
that that's in fatty fish okay it's in
cod liver oil and i will say you can get
it from algae if you want to eat algae
okay but it's going to be in this fatty
fish
now sometimes people will confuse
a version of the omega-3 called ala with
the active form of omega-3
called epa or dha so they might say that
walnuts are are loaded with omega-3
fatty acids well walnuts have the um
precursor it's the ala
okay that has to turn into the epa which
then has to turn into the dha
so what is the conversion on that well
ala to epa is like only eight percent
and epa to dha is only zero to four
percent so if you're trying to build up
your omega-3
and you're going to try to do it with
walnuts
you're probably going to get a little
bit but you're not going to get a lot
but believe me i eat walnuts i love
walnuts but i'm not trying to get my
omega-3 fatty acids from walnuts and as
a side note when you sprout the walnuts
you can release and get rid of some of
these
anti-nutrients so that's going to help
as well all right what about essential
amino acids or complete amino acid
profiles can you get them from grains
can you get them from beans no not
directly you'd have to combine things
and know how to do it but guess what
when you consume meat fish eggs and
organ meats you get all of the essential
amino acids and all of your
bio-available nutrients so over here you
create nutritional deficiencies and over
here you satisfy any deficiencies you
have
this is way more complete and way more
bioavailable to your body now since
we're on the topic of foods and
nutrition i think the best next video
for you to watch
would be relating to giving you more
examples of these foods right here check
it out it's right here